my name is guillermo rauch i'm the
creator of soccer ao
also co-founder and cto of a startup
called learnboost
in the education space
um
so i assume as many of you might be
aware of
soccerio is a way of doing real-time
applications on every browser
also a server now
with a simple api that resembles
websocket a lot
so so far we've seen a lot of adoption
and
many applications deployed to production
with it and many projects created with
it and with that we've learned some
lessons and
we've
um
finally come up with a spec of how other
people that might want socket ao and the
socket io protocol on other
servers and other languages might go
about creating it
so
the goal for the next release of socket
ao
that has been already pushed to uh
github in an alpha state
is sort of implementing this spec
uh implementing the sort of new features
that are going to be the foundation of
socket ao
and uh so that's what i'm gonna talk
about today
first of all uh i made some
architectural changes
the uh like i said the protocol the
socareo protocol which is
what we need essentially to make
websocket and long polling or other
transports converge and maintain
sessions for users so they we can for
example buffer messages on the server
and the client
um
we have we have made some
api changes so that it's easier to get
up and running
uh we have an um a new way of doing
tests which basically is um
i created an uh node client that i'm
gonna use to test the node server and
vice versa
um
so before each time you would run socket
ao you were limited to storing every
message and every user and every session
id on one process of one computer so if
that process were to die or you wanted
to use two computers to handle a number
a higher number of messages per second
or a higher number of connected users
you basically had to create a message
basically implement a message dispatcher
yourself you would subscribe clients to
a redis set or pop sub or you would use
a rabbit mq
so today
soca is going to take care of that for
you
and also
another
important thing is
many people have different needs as far
as
how much latency they can afford for
their applications so some people might
want to just completely ditch
the flash transport because it adds a
lot of bloat and they can afford to use
long polling as a fallback transport so
um
i've made the handshake process and i've
made the socket interfaces more
configurable so that you can
easily decide what transports you want
to use and other options
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
new api
um
so i we made uh some we made it easier
to run a socket ao server that is not
tied to a particular http server so
before you have to instantiate it
yourself
now you can simply
call io.listen or pass it a board and
you'll have your own standalone socket a
server
before you would have to pass this
huge object of options with nested
objects of options and now
we have express like configuration
so we can have you can have different
settings for development and production
which for a project like socket ao is
extremely important
sometimes your clients might be dropping
because of network latency or you're
testing a mobile device so you want to
make sure you know why a certain client
is dropping is it because a heartbeat
wasn't
received or is it because
the client is too slow uh for this for
your settings so uh you can customize
things as the logger the log level
um so like i said uh up until today you
were constricted to one process in one
server
we made some changes to
make that
more flexible so by default you'll still
it is going to continue to store
everything in memory the main reason is
that not everyone has requirements to
set up socadeo in a cluster or
perform worker process replacements
with tools like cluster or multi-node
like like i said it defaults to memory
and one thing that we had to change in
order to make these two modes of
operating
compatible is that every
signature that before was
just accessing memory now is an async
callback so from your socket ao instance
if you needed to access a client list
before you would go socket ao. clients
and now you're going to go secondary
clients and pass it a function
something really useful as well is the
ability to associate data with a
particular client so when someone
connects um
we can for example set a nickname and
that's going to leverage the same
existing storage that you're using for
your messages and for
your message keys so if someone connects
and you want to sort the nickname
they're going to have for the session
you can do that uh directly from
soccerio as well
another thing that is really important
is
the ability to send messages that
can be dropped and should not be
buffered so for example if you are
creating an application that displays
tweets or you're creating an application
that
you want to show the latest stock prices
to the users you don't want to and
you're retrieving stock prices every
second but you have a client that is
only taking messages every five seconds
or so you don't want to buffer every
single message you you want socket ao to
drop some of them so that you always
receive the latest
so that's what the volatile flag does
and it's really easy to use so before
you would uh
you would say socket.send and you would
send a message to the user so
now by simply prefixing it with volatile
you can make that message
forgettable so if sockadio cannot write
it to the user which is
important for example for long polling
where the client is opening requests and
response cycles and we're only able to
write data to the user whenever they
open their request but between between
two requests and sorry between a request
and a response we cannot write to the
user because it's not server push so
those messages would be dropped while
the user is temporarily not connected
another flag that i'm adding is called
json so before sakereo was smart enough
to detect that you were sending
something that was not a string and
serialize it into json
so the problem is that even strings can
be serialized into json so if you want
to force
100 json in coding you can also use the
json flag and you can combine them so if
you want to send json as a as a volatile
message you just concatenate them
another really useful thing is
acknowledgments so sometimes so the way
that websocket works you write a message
you never get a call back unless you
implement it yourself so you can send a
message that is prefixed by an id
and then have your server respond with
that particular id so you would get an
acknowledgement that your message has
been received by the server
so i built the machinery for
acknowledgments into the socket ao
protocol and implementing it as a
developer as a user of the library is
extremely easy
so every time you send a message if you
pass a function as the last parameter
that's going to send that's going to
append an id to the to the message that
is being sent
through the wire
and the client will respond and it's
also symmetrical so a client can send a
message that has a callback associated
with it and the server will respond with
an acknowledgement
another thing that it was actually um
requested many times
and
it really doesn't add any bloat to the
protocol and and that's the main reason
that it's been added is the ability to
define your custom events
so
you can still use socket ao as a on
connect on message and on disconnect
but
certain applications will fit other
semantics better so if you're creating a
chat application you might want user
connected user joined room user sending
private messages so now you can define
these events and they are sent through
the socket a protocol in a very
lightweight way
so instead of going um
sorry here it's not i io on chat message
is socket dot on chat message
um essentially you can define uh custom
the event emitter is overwritten for
socket ao so you can define your custom
events and emit custom events
for
events that are user-defined the uh
the parameters that you send are json
encoded that means that you can send
objects you can send strings dates um
or any other encodable entity
so like i said events have no protocol
overhead
they are optional you can still use
socket ao as a cross browser websocket
if you like constrain yourself to the
three basic events
and again it's compatible with flags and
acknowledgements so
um like i said it's always uh events
always use json but if you want to send
a volatile event so if you're listening
on a twitter stream and you want to send
a tweet event and you might want to drop
some of them you can do that by
prefixing the
emit by a with a volatile flag
and something interesting is that
an acknowledgement from an
implementation point of view is just the
server sending us a packet back that is
basically an empty string
but sometimes you might want to
acknowledge with actual data so you
might want to
you might want to say
emit a nickname event and as as part of
the result get
get a response of whether the nickname
could be set or not or if it was being
used by another user in the case of a
chat application
and
that's also something that events
empower
essentially when you um
when you emit
an event
if the
functionarity
meaning the number of arguments that are
defined in the function that you pass it
as a callback for the acknowledgement is
greater than zero so in this case i'm
setting and emitting a nickname event
and the function expects a response
object
so socket a will know that
your function the server side has to
respond with data so in this case i'm
performing an asynchronous task which is
checking for the availability of that
nickname
and this is really powerful because
there's many semantics that do not
require acknowledgement and do not
require data back from the server so for
example publishing a message to a stream
but there's many that do and events give
you this functionality now
so finally
moving forward with the project
one thing i would like to see is people
creating reusable applications and not
just frameworks so today we have
frameworks like d node and juggernaut
which are awesome but
if if we want
this to become mainstream and we want to
really enable
people that are creating web 2.0
applications to start inserting
components of the real-time web we need
to make sure that we can distribute
pre-packaged applications
and to that end we need to solve
basically one problem which is
preventing collisions and
if you have a particular i o socket ao
instance
you need some machinery for two
different applications to share that
without having to initialize two
different ones
so if
two two particular parts of your website
depend on websocket that's fine you have
two connections but if they depend on
long polling depending on the browser
and how many resources are being loaded
and how many keep a live sockets are
open uh you might end up with like four
different connections just for your two
sockets
so the idea is that we want to be able
to reuse a particular sockario instance
but be able to namespace it
and uh to that end i added the ability
to like
socket subscribe to channels
without
the user knowing or having to
particularly subscribe or understand the
pops of uh kind of
mechanism
and the way it works is really simple so
by default uh the when you define a
socket it's gonna
subscribe to the
empty namespace
that's the default again you can
continue to use socket ao with as
basically a websocket
all the messages go through the same
stream
but you can also define a namespace just
by prefixing your uh event listening
with four so
that particular socket for the news
endpoint is gonna act as a standalone
socket even though it's gonna go through
the through the same
tcp connections
a multiplexing is automatic even on the
client side
um if on the client side you define the
same host name the same port and the
same protocol but you only change the
resource part of the url then
multiplexing will be enabled for you and
packets that signal connection and this
connection of events
of this socket will be sent which means
you can actually disconnect the chat
socket and keep the new socket connected
and that means that every single event
or every single message that you send is
constrained to that particular namespace
so this also fits really well into how
you could make your own applications
even if you're not reusing third-party
code
so you might have an event called item
or an event called message but they are
actually two different things in two
different name spaces
and as far as uh where
what we're working on right now and
what's coming for the project
um
so
it
it's obvious that express is a
mainstream uh web framework for node
it's the framework that the community
chose
and we need that really easy way to
leverage and connect session data with
sockets so a really common need is like
okay so someone connected
through a socket on a particular page
but i want to retrieve
what's his username or what's his email
from the database
and to this end
the solution is really simple
by
having a token of authentication that
express
and socket eo can inter exchange they
can you can know on what page the user
is on what part what particular route
and who the user is
so this is a separate project that's
coming for express users
another thing that is
challenging right now is testing
different browsers so every time you
make a change to the client and or the
server we need to see if ie6 works
and today
till today it's been largely a manual
process combined with really simple unit
testing and obviously unit testing is
not enough uh considering the many
quirks that browsers have
so
um one thing i'm going to do is set up
auto automatic uh cloud testing uh on
selenium so that we we're gonna be able
to
as soon as we push to github we're going
to be able to test on all the browsers
we want to support
there's been also many problems related
to the flash fallback
that range from
sometimes increasing the latency to uh
really high memory consumption
to
um
slowness when
https and ssl
are used
and also the fact that socket sakurai
without flash is around
8 kilobytes and with flash is like i
know like 200 kilobytes
and that's a problem so
we're gonna be working on
our own flash fallback
and we're probably not gonna be
supporting ssl with it because that's
what adds the most bloat to uh to the
flash um movie is the fact that uh the
ssl crypto libraries are not built in
into
actionscript
there is also an upcoming websocket spec
that
browsers will be supporting soon
including firefox 4
and as soon as a major stable browser
supports it we want to support it
and so that's it you can check out the
repo for the latest code
and if you have any questions
so you're asking if it should be connect
that ao or so
yeah that's a great question and
so the session middleware
um which is one of the things that we
want to connect with socket ao
is basically connect it's not express so
to that end we yeah and there is a
project already for that
but
my
other thing is my the ability to create
to connect the templates to real-time
events
and to that end we need to make it
express
and there's also the fact that not many
people use connect without express
while leveraging the session middleware
you might want to use connect if you're
like just serving static files or static
pages like uh html and some images you
might just want to use connect but when
you're actually leveraging the session
middleware you're probably using express
so
um
i just went with express.ao
so he's asking about how we're going to
do cross browser cross-platform testing
so
for our company we also have the problem
of supporting multiple browsers and we
want to have acceptance testing that
where that makes sure that things work
on webkit which is a browser we develop
on but also is x
so we created an adapter uh for node
called soda
what soda does is implement selenium
and potentially
if you want to use sauce labs sauce labs
is a startup that provides a service for
automating testing with selenium on the
cloud in the cloud so
instead of you setting up your own
cluster and your like set of computers
running windows
and
ie and all the different variations of
combinations you can use sauce labs and
you pay per minute
and it's also free for linux and firefox
so you can get started doing acceptance
testing with uh
that way and that's what we're gonna
leverage so we're gonna
write unit tests
and we're also gonna connect to like a
fixed uh socket ao server and we're
gonna just basically produce output to
that page
then
selenium will connect to that page and
check for a number of positives and
negatives and if it fails um sawslabs
will give you a video of what happened
so you can know exactly like okay what
test failed or what's the output or
what's the javascript console saying
he's asking if it's been difficult to
keep up with the websocket spec
and the answer is actually no because
at first we had uh
so in the very first node
days we there was no http upgrade event
so we had to implement websocket as a
net server so the http parser and the
http node implementation didn't give us
the hooks to have a
websocket server without a patch so
initially socket you had to like patch
node to have
a websocket server on top of the http
server
otherwise you would have to run it in a
different port
so then we had to support the initial
spec which was draft 75
and after that shortly after we had to
support draft draft 76
and since then the spec hasn't changed
at all
now it's it's going to change and it's
going to change in some pretty major
ways
but the struggles with websocket have
not been
mostly implementing this spec it's been
for example the fact that they are
supposed to bypass proxies that's one of
the design goals of the websocket
protocol was
we need to make this thing bypass
proxies that are
in on the internet today which is not
the case so websocket fails so socket ao
needed the machinery to to determine oh
i couldn't connect with the websocket
i'm going to try something else so on
that end it's been a difficult decision
to make websocket the
first choice because long polling ends
up being more reliable for most use
cases
but hopefully that's going to change now
with the new spec
and
it and that should be the definite one
that uh firefox expressed interest in
implementing and uh so that's chrome and
safari
and ie9 so i9 has the same um ambition
to implement this spec and today they
are doing it with
silverlight
or through like labs plugins
but hopefully it's also going to be part
of i9
all right uh thank you so much uh
i'm gonna post the slides to twitter if
you want to see them later
you